5 41 on a tuesday morning and this is
the start as you're getting ready this
morning it's amazon prime day perhaps
you're already shopping for sweet deals
online while you're crushing your cereal
yeah you're like doing this drinking
your coffee multitasking yeah we're all
good at this but all that shopping does
have a cost down the line prime day ends
up being very busy for republic services
mary jane belly has it joining us live
now at republic services with how
they're gearing up for this huge two-day
event good morning mary jane
john and heather good morning to you
according to amazon more than 250
million items were purchased during last
year's two-day shopping spree so that's
a ton of plastic cardboard boxes and
even bubble wrap to go through public
services is doing their part to make
sure all of that is properly recycled
and joining me brian early this morning
is jeremy walters with public services
and jeremy thanks so much for being here
now we know with a lot of items comes a
lot of different types of packaging so
it's important to really kind of
sort out what needs to be properly
recycled can you tell us the do's and
don'ts yeah you know there are some
things that are better suited for
recycling than others obviously the
cardboard box is fantastic for recycling
but there's a lot of different plastic
materials that come through your
e-commerce experience
those white amazon satchels those sort
of bubble wrap packages those are
actually not recyclable and if you look
at the recycling symbol itself it'll say
store drop off only so you can return
them to a participating store for
recycling but they don't belong in your
curbside bin along with that is those
air filled pillow packs that pad the uh
item you purchased inside your box those
are not recyclable curbside either so
those flexible plastics actually create
all sorts of challenges for us here at
the recycling center one thing that
we've seen change uh through that
ecommerce experience is that amazon is
switching some of those uh white
flexible plastic satchels and shifting
to paper satchels those brown paper
satchels are actually actually
recyclable alongside your cardboard box
as well wow so all good things to really
remember as many of you at home are
online shopping or getting ready to
online shop just remember all these
important recycling tips really go a
long way in making sure that they stay
out of our landfills reporting live mary
jane balleza live local now